bonjour à toutes et à tous je vois que
la salle se remplit progressivement on
est heureux d'accueillir celles et ceux
qui nous rejoignent depuis quelques
minutes on a voulu débuter cette cette
journée ces deux journées de rendez vous
ici de notre jeunesse sur un sujet
essentiel pour nous qui essuient
l'engagement local et je suis heureux
d'accueillir autour de moi plusieurs
personnes qui avec guillaume guérin un
qui va animer à mes côtés cette table
ronde on va vous présenter ici des
femmes et des hommes qui depuis de
nombreuses années ont consacré
l'intégralité de leur énergie leur
détermination leur conviction de leur
volonté à servir leurs concitoyens et
c'est là une des grandes marques de
fabrique de notre famille politique nous
ne sommes pas un parti politique hors
sol nous ne venons pas de nulle part et
pour beaucoup d'entre nous y compris les
parlementaires nous avons commencé
d'abord en servons nos concitoyens au
plus près du terrain et cette école-là
celle de la république du quotidien
c'est une école qui est absolument
fondamentale vous avez ici des femmes et
des hommes qui vont échanger avec vous
et se présenter tout à l'heure
dont vous verrez que ils sont tous des
enfants de la république que pour
beaucoup d'entre nous la plupart n'était
pas écrit il ya quelques années qu'un
jour nous devenions ou maires ou élus
départementaux ou élus régionaux ou
sénateurs ou députés et pourtant la
république notre pays nos convictions
nos valeurs nous ont permis un jour de
servir nos concitoyens et
progressivement d'accéder à des
responsabilités parfois plus nationale
et c'est ce dont nous allons parler
aujourd'hui
on n'imaginait pas débuter ces deux
journées sans avoir d'abord un temps
essentiel sur l'engagement vous dire
avant de présenter chacun qu'il y a
quelques années nous étions exactement à
votre place qu'il y a quelques années il
y avait en face de nous des femmes et
des hommes qui nous raconter la même
histoire que celle que je vous raconte
qui vous disaient que tout était
possible dans la vie politique tout
était possible dans notre pays et dans
notre république et que si on le voulait
un jour on pouvait servir nos
concitoyens par le mandat et c'est vrai
qu'il ya quelques années peut-être qu'on
le croyait pas à chaque fois peut-être
qu'on pensait que c'était toujours des
belles histoires qu'on nous racontait
mais qu'elle n'était pas réalisable est
ce que nous voulons vous dire est ce que
nous allons vous dire durant plus d'une
heure c'est que c'est tout à fait
possible que si vous avez au fond de vos
tripes la volonté de servir la volonté
de défendre des convictions la volonté
de faire en sorte qu'on vive mieux
demain la volonté de porter un espoir
alors il n'y a aucune espèce de raison
pour qu'un jour vous ne deveniez pas élu
de la république c'est ce qui marque la
fabrique de notre famille politique ce
sont les victoires départementale ce
sont les victoires aux régionales ce
sont les victoires aux municipales et
c'est ce qu'il fera à l'évidence notre
prochaine victoire aux élections
présidentielles sans plus tarder je vous
présente les différents intervenants
guillaume guérin qui est à mes côtés
président de limoges métropole président
du groupe d'opposition à la région
nouvelle aquitaine depuis désormais
quelques mois je vais le laisser se
présenter mais avant je vais faire un
petit tour d'horizon pour vous ayez en
tête chacune des personnalités qui vont
nous entoure et je suis heureux
d'accueillir gilles averous que vous
connaissez tous que vous pouvez
évidemment applaudir et président du
comité des maires dans notre famille
politique qui est maire de châteauroux
qui se présentera plus en détail tout à
l'heure et nous racontera la belle
aventure qui est la sienne depuis de
nombreuses années je suis heureux
d'accueillir alexandre à bord qui au
fond d'un notre collègue sénatrice des
alpes-maritimes qui est aussi
conseillère départementale et qui a un
long vécu d'élu local avant même d'avoir
eu lieu ses fonctions au sénat michel
andres sanchez
que vous pouvez largement applaudir qui
est maire d'erstein j'imagine qu'on dit
comme ça et référente du comité des
maires pour le bas rhin othman nassr ou
bienvenue ici dans ta région
les vice-présidents la région ile de
france élu d'opposition à trappes depuis
désormais plusieurs années olivier
capitanio président du département du
val de marne on est ici chez toi
presque presque chez toi et christian a
dit tous les espoirs que tu aurais
porter toute la fierté que nous avons de
te savoir désormais enfin hortense
chartier qui conseillère municipale
d'opposition à bruges et qui est avec
nous aujourd'hui guillaume je te laisse
la parole pour lancer les discussions
merci aurélien bonjour à toutes et à
tous je tenais à remercier en priorité
le président des jeunes républicains
guillem carayon pour cette magnifique
organisation sous la houlette d'aurélien
et et de christian et remercié les
jeunes pour la tenue remarquable de leur
élection interne parce que nous le
savons tous ici les jeunes ont parfois
les mêmes travers que leurs aînés avec
la fougue de la jeunesse et ces
élections internes à notre mouvement se
sont excessivement bien passé tu l'a
rappelé christian et donc pour moi c'est
un honneur et une fierté d'être à vos
côtés aujourd'hui et bravo encore à
guilhem et à son équipe pour cette
remarquable organisation
me présenter très rapidement je suis
président de la fédération des
républicains de la haute-vienne je suis
président de limoges métropole c'est une
aire urbaine de 215 milles habitants la
gauche comme olivier je la connais bien
dans mon département puisque nous avons
eu trois maires en un siècle limoges
c'est une ville de 140 mille habitants
et nous avons eu trois maires
socialistes en un siècle 102 ans de
d'hégémonie socialiste jusqu'en 2014 un
basculement historique en 2014 et le
basculement de la communauté urbaine en
2020 ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui de
pouvoir développer nos politiques
publiques et ce qui met ce qu'il ya
confronter mon engagement initial qui
datent de l'ump puisque ma première
carte j'avais votre âge j'avais 16 ans
la première fois que je me suis engagé
pour un certain nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque
aurélien merci de ton invitation me
présentais très très rapidement et dire
aux jeunes qu'en politique rien n'est
impossible si vous êtes là aujourd'hui
vous avez entre 16 et 30 ans vous croyez
aux idées qui sont les nôtres vous
croyez que nous sommes le parti qui peut
amener une alternance à ce pays et qui
peut porter les belles choses pour notre
nation et plus largement pour notre pour
notre continent européen est ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que vous ne vous
êtes pas trompés ne voudrais pas trompés
parce que vous êtes et qu'il aime vous
pouvez l'applaudir chaleureusement
redevenu le premier mouvement jeune de
france
[Applaudissements]
l'engagement d'un élu local c'est quoi
c'est porter des idées devant ses
concitoyens sans mettre son drapeau dans
sa poche christian tu le disais c'est
arrivé à convaincre des gens qui ne sont
pas traditionnellement convaincu car
vous savez vous l'avez vu à l'échelle de
l'hexagone les socles politique des
formations politiques traditionnelles
se sont considérablement affaissé ces
dernières années et donc il s'agit sur
une élection locale de convaincre que
votre programme municipal ou que votre
programme départemental ou régional est
meilleur que celui de vos adversaires et
une fois que vous êtes élu c'est de
porter des politiques publiques et bien
moi je veux dire aux jeunes qu'il faut
pas hésiter à vous engager fermement
parfois à batailler et auprès de vos
seniors pour pouvoir avoir des positions
éligibles sur les listes pour porter les
idées que vous avez développé au cours
d'une campagne dans votre programme
parce que quand vous êtes un élu local
vous servez l'intérêt de vos concitoyens
au quotidien pour ma part je préside la
communauté urbaine de limoges la
communauté urbaine c'est quoi c'est le
transport en commun c'est la voirie
c'est l'assainissement c'est le
développement économique
bref c'est ce qui régit le quotidien de
chacune et de chacun d'entre vous et
c'est le plus beau des engagements que
d'avoir un mandat local pour concrétiser
ce que vous pensez juste pour l'avenir
de vos concitoyens donc engagez vous
nous manquons de jeunes vous savez il ya
eu besoin de légiférer au 21ème siècle
pour qu'il y ait la parité sur les
listes
j'espère qu'on ne sera pas contraint un
jour de légiférer pour qu'il y ait une
pyramide des âges à peu près homogène
dans les listes représentant les
différentes formations politiques à la
proportionnelle donc engager vous
bousculer vos aînés qui parfois ont du
mal à nous laisser la place aux
passantes et donc n'hésitez pas à les
bousculer nous avons besoin dans ce pays
d'une jeunesse et d'une jeunesse de
droite qui s'affirme merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
gilles averous président de la métropole
président du comité des mères excuse moi
et maire de cette magnifique ville de
châteauroux que tu a transformé durant
plusieurs années raconte tout ce qui un
jour fait que tu t'engages en politique
quels sont les passages les plus
compliqués que tu as pu connaître parce
que c'est pas toujours une vie simple et
ce qui fait aujourd'hui la fierté de
tout engagement au service de ses
concitoyens
merci aurélien bonjour à toutes et à
tous alors effectivement moins bon mon
engagement il commence à dater un peu
date de 1995 1995 avait 22 ans et j'ai
décidé à ce moment là j'étais amoureux
de mon village mais j'ai à dire comme
beaucoup d'entre nous et on s'attache à
la terre sur laquelle on est on a envie
de servir est aujourd'hui la thématique
la table ronde assez parlé de
l'engagement si vous êtes là aujourd'hui
déjà c'est que vous avez déjà fait le
choix de vous engager d'adhérer un
mouvement de représenter les autres de
servir les autres bah c'était exactement
ces valeurs là c'est pilier un peu de ce
qui fait un territoire un terroir qui
m'ont amené dans mon village à me dire
voilà j'ai envie de transformer les
choses j'ai envie de faire des travaux
moi j'étais passionné des chantiers tout
ça je me suis dit qui peut changer au
quotidien l'environnement dans lequel on
évolue les conseillers municipaux je me
suis faut que j'aille faut que je me
présente au conseil municipal dans ma
commune je connaissais personne enfin
dans le conseil municipal j'étais pas
d'une famille de gens dans lesquels on
avait des élus naturellement chez moi
personne faisait de la politique dans ma
famille ni de près ni de loin et donc
j'ai décidé d'y aller de conduire une
liste avec des gens que j'ai repéré
comme étant des gens qui s'engageait
dans la cité et je crois que à l'instant
guillaume disait allez voir les élus
pour intégrer les équipes c'est un moyen
effectivement le deuxième c'est vous
mêmes vous investir 2 peut-être membres
d'associations sportives culturelles
puisque nous maintenant que je suis
passé de l'autre côté de la barrière et
que à chaque renouvellement municipal je
me dis tiens comment on fait pour
renouveler une partie de l'équipe
comment remplace ce qu ont servi qui
vont partir à la retraite ou qu'ils
quittent la commune et bien
prioritairement je prends ce que j'ai
repéré tout au long de l'année dans les
sorties dans les représentations qu'on
fait tout ce que j'ai vu servir les
autres s'engager dans les associations
et donner d'eux-mêmes et les instances
locales que ce soit l'échelle municipale
intercommunale départementale plus que
des lieux de pouvoir sont des lieux de
voir sont des lieux dans lesquels les
élus servent les autres j'ai tendance à
dire ça peut-être choquer mes collègues
parlementaires fin les élus
parlementaires mais les lieux de pouvoir
c'est à paris c'est à l'assemblée c'est
au gouvernement sur le territoire dans
les départements c'est plutôt des lieux
de voir on est là pour servir les autres
nos citoyens attendent beaucoup de nous
et même un maire d'arrondissement j'en
ai une devant moi et elle sait ce que
c'est la proximité avec le citoyen fait
qu'ils sont très exigeants voilà donc
l'engagement c'est ça en fait c'est
l'engagement de servir les autres et je
voudrais vraiment remercier christian
jacob parce qu il a compris ce que
c'était avec la force des élus d'un
territoire et il a souhaité relancer le
comité des mères c'est à dire structuré
département par département l'ensemble
des maires de france ont fait une grande
famille mais on se connaissait peu et
grâce à l'action et l'impulsion qu'il a
donnée on est en train de construire
quelque chose de solide et c'est
vraiment cet ancrage territorial qui
fait la différence entre nous et les
autres mouvements qu'on peut côtoyer au
quotidien merci à vous de votre
engagement continuer comme ça et compter
sur les élus aussi pour vous aider dans
vos missions commerciales
bien elle va se elle va maintenant se
présenter elle même mais nous avons à
nos côtés la sénatrice la jeune
sénatrice des alpes-maritimes alexandra
boursiers au fond d'un lac estion que
j'aurais envie de te poser alexandra
sait comment as tu fait dans cette terre
des alpes-maritimes une terre où la
droite est fortement implanté et où les
hommes de droite ont souvent une
prépondérance à prendre les différents
postes comment toi en tant que jeune
femme tu as réussi à te poser dans cet
univers de droite plutôt masculin des
alpes-maritimes
bonjour à tous
si ça marche j'en profite pour saluer
mes amis un michel et philippe tabarot
qui viennent de nous rejoindre et qui
sont mes amis des alpes-maritimes du
coup je me sens un peu moins seul
aujourd'hui bonjour à tous je suis
impressionné par ce rassemblement comme
disait aurélien et à quelques années il
y avait les universités d'été l air dans
les alpes-maritimes je vous rassure il
faisait aussi chaud et j'étais à votre
place et j'écoutais aussi des
intervenants qui m'ont donné envie de
m'engager des hommes et des femmes bien
sûr des parlementaires des maires qui
ont oeuvré pour leur territoire et je
crois que l'engagement c'est là bas
justement pour se construire c'est
tellement important d'être inspiré
michèle tabarot ici présent fait partie
des femmes politiques les plus
importantes de france éminente dans les
alpes-maritimes et ce sont des portraits
des personnalités qui donne envie de
s'engager il s'engage parce qu'ils
travaillent parce qu'ils y croient et je
crois que c'est ça le coeur
véritablement de votre engagement alors
bousculé
c'est vrai qu'on parlait des quotas des
femmes peut-être on devra arriver aux
joues un jour aussi aux quotas des
jeunes peut-être qu'il faut passer par
là pour essayer de rajeunir les conseils
municipaux en tout cas pour ce qui est
de ma part j'ai toujours continué à
oeuvrer à m'engager sachez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya énormément de
jeunes énormément de domme je vois
malheureusement pas assez de jeunes
filles deux jeunes femmes c'est
important de s'engager sachez vous
pouvez continuer à avoir une activité
professionnelle à fonder une famille à
poursuivre votre engagement de bénévoles
peut-être dans l'association dans
laquelle vous êtes tout ça n'est pas
incompatible g
ici je me suis engagé en 2008 j'avais
donc 26 ans j'ai fait mes enfants
pendant mes mandats et ça n'a pas
empêché aujourd'hui à 38 ans d'être élue
sénatrice des pins maritimes alors
peut-être que je suis parlementaire
aussi aujourd'hui grâce à la loi sur la
parité en tout cas le vais vous la
france a besoin de vous la france a
besoin de jeunesse si vous êtes là
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez quelque
chose à dire quelque chose à faire et
nous on en a besoin on est ici des élus
plutôt de la jeune génération à s'être
engagés alors on est loin d'être des
modèles et des exemples mais en tout cas
ce qu'on veut vous dire aujourd'hui par
nos témoignages respectifs c'est qu'on
peut y arriver alors si vous avez des
choses à dire lever vous la france a
besoin de vous
[Applaudissements]
merci alexandre à un jeune mère qui est
à nos côtés aujourd'hui qu'aurélien à
présenter rapidement tout à l'heure
michel henry ou sanchez de l'est de la
france une région bien connue dans cette
salle monsieur le maire vous y avez une
question à vous poser pourquoi tout
simplement vous êtes engagé six jeunes
pour conquérir cette mairie et quels
enseignements vous tirez
en termes d'enrichissement personnel
dans votre mandat
bonjour à tous
alors comment comment est venue l'idée
d'aider municipal bas à vrai dire pour
être tout à fait honnête elle s'est
passé autour d'un café dans la ville
dans laquelle j'ai grandi dans laquelle
j'ai discuté avec un certain nombre
d'habitants qui vient se poser des
questions sur l'avenir de la commune sur
son développement sur ses
infrastructures et en fait au fur et à
mesure du temps à cette époque là
j'étais encore collaborateur
parlementaire dont de la sénatrice
esther sittler qui était chez nous et
finalement elle me dit mais pense à
s'engager encore plus loin va toujours
plus loin j'ai commencé comme ça j'étais
jeune à l'époque elle était une femme
dans les années 80 elle disait tu sais à
l'époque c'était justement difficile en
étant une femme de s'engager vas-y et
sur le mans et bien j'ai réfléchi je me
suis dit finalement bah oui même si
j'avais 23 ans je me suis dit il est
toujours temps de s'engager encore plus
pour sa ville pour son pays et ensuite
j'ai tout simplement pris mon bâton de
pèlerin quasiment un an avant l'élection
en allant rencontrer on le disait avant
les forces vives de nos communes les
associations les personnes qui ont un
fort relais d'opinion dans la commune
des personnes qui sont déjà aussi engagé
pour la ville et puis en fait au fur et
à mesure du temps on a commencé à
construire une équipe on a commencé à se
poser la question de comment on voudrait
voir le développement d'autres communes
sur dix ans et finalement on est allé
voir au fur et à mesure du temps eh bien
les habitants ont nécessairement quand
on s'engage à cet âge là au début la
vraie question sur laquelle on travaille
c'est n'est-il pas trop jeune c'est
toujours la question qu'on a posés et à
vrai dire j'en parlais souvent à ma mon
ancienne patronne en lui disant bas
finalement on me dit souvent oui mais il
a 24 ans et ce qu'il n'a pas le temps de
faire autre chose et finalement
en en discutant avec des habitants qui
dit oui mais vous n'êtes pas justement
trop jeune je dis pas écouté puisque
vous le pensez jamais égalé et
finalement on a vraiment pris comme je
disais ce bâton de pèlerin et au premier
tour on est sorti et bien premier à 46%
des suffrages bon le coc vide a été
véritablement quelque chose de singulier
on s'est demandé si là on va dire
l'élection allait être encore tenues et
où finalement on a fait encore un
meilleur score au deuxième tour voilà
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
othman nassr où tu es vice président de
la région ile de france je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est un deuxième mandat
comme vice président de cette région qui
est une région qui ressemble à aucune
autre et qui dit beaucoup de l'état de
notre de notre pays on sait ton
engagement sur beaucoup de sujets en
vous écoutant j'ai une question je
voudrais poser parce que qu'on est à peu
près la réponse dans ta bouche je pense
qu'elle peut intéresser ceux qui nous
écoutent fond on est dans une époque où
on parle beaucoup de politique sur les
plateaux de télévision on fait beaucoup
de métal politique cette politique qui
change pas la vie des gens qui intéresse
nos esprits qui nous fait perdre permet
une gymnastique intellectuelle et qui
quotidiennement ne change pas la vie de
celui qui va prendre le métro le matin
qui va aller bosser dur qui a des
difficultés dans sa famille etc etc
comment quand on est vice président de
la région ile de france on arrive à
faire en sorte que ses convictions ses
valeurs de droite avec tout ce que ça
comporte d'espoir pour l'avenir on
arrive à les concrétiser et à passer au
fond des plateaux de télé c'est souvent
très confortable d'avoir des idées au
terrain où on les implique concrètement
comment est ce qu'on fait ça quand on
est vice président de la région ile de
france
merci aurélien bonjour à toutes et à
tous et merci infiniment à christian
jacob à killem carayon pour
l'organisation de cette journée pour
leur invitation et quelle fierté de voir
tous aussi nombreux pour pouvoir dire
clairement que la droite c'est l'avenir
et vous leur présentez tous ici et je
veux ne peut pas ne pas le dire en tant
que président de la région avec plus de
600 jeunes franciliens qui sont là c'est
un motif de fierté merci à toutes et à
tous et pas question rien elle a le
mérite d'être extrêmement clair c'est
c'est bien d'avoir les valeurs comporte
que certains d'ailleurs vite compris à
gauche nous parle souvent de grandes de
grande valeur de grands concepts de
justice sociale de générosité de
solidarité mais sur le terrain on voit
souvent que ce sont nos élus nos élus de
la droite qui ont été plébiscités à
l'occasion des élections locales qui ont
été reconduits fièrement parce que ils
n'ont pas eu la main qui tremble quand
il a fallu mettre en accord et bien tout
simplement leur valeur avec les
décisions qu'il devait prendre y compris
parfois en allant au delà de leur sujet
et singulièrement pour les régions
durant la crise sanitaire ici en
ile-de-france avec valérie pécresse sur
la sécurité sur la live et sur le
déménagement du siège de la région sur
les économies de fonctionnement sur la
bonne gestion qui nous est reconnue
partout sur notre territoire aujourd'hui
pour les maires et les élus locaux de la
droite et du centre mais aurélien il ya
une chose surtout d'enjeux j'aimerais
ici le dire clairement sur la fierté qui
doit être celle des jeunes je crois que
vous pouvez être fiers de vous engager
pour un pays qui le mérite et je n'ai
pas pour habitude de parler trop
simplement de moi mais je vais le dire
ici moi il ya dix ans je n'étais pas
français
je suis aujourd'hui vice-président de la
première région d'europe je laisserai
jamais dire que ce pays est un pays
raciste
je ne laisserai jamais
et comme toi aurélien je viens d'une
famille comme temps rien ne vient ni
famille où personne ne faisait de
politique et donc j'ai fait le choix de
devenir français je suis fier d'avoir
fait ce choix et donc n'ayez jamais on
de vous engager pour ce pays qui le
mérite qui est un des rares pays au
monde à permettre cette promesse
universelle cette promesse républicaine
qui est une réalité et vous avez une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de tous les
entrepreneurs identitaire qui tiennent à
notre jeunesse un discours de repli de
victimisation de de détestation de
l'histoire de france 2 déboulonnement de
nos statuts voilà le message de fierté
je voulais vous dire
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup aux bad on aura
l'occasion de revenir vers chacune et
chacun d'entre vous je pense que vous
comprenez pourquoi nous voulions ouvrir
ces deux journées sur ces témoignages la
voilà ce qui est non seulement la france
mais aussi ce qui est notre famille
politique c'est à droite que le mérite
s'incarne quotidiennement j'en viens au
président du département voisin si je
comprends bien on n'est pas tout à fait
dans son département est ce que tu peux
nous dire comment et christian l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure comment est-ce que
lorsqu'on est un homme de droite comme
toi fier de ses convictions et de ses
valeurs on arrive à conquérir ce
département en réussissant un défi
immense qui ne jamais renier ses
convictions mais de rassembler tout le
monde y compris des concitoyens qui
n'ont pas nos valeurs parce que la
réalité c'est qu'on ne gagne pas aux
élections locales si on fait pas plus de
50% comme à toutes les élections et donc
parfois on va au delà même de notre
famille politique comme en ont réussi ce
défi de leur donner envie à ceux qui
sont parfois éloignés de nous de nous
faire confiance et de rejoindre nos
convictions
alors tout d'abord très heureux d'être
avec vous cet après midi vraiment et
puis je voudrais m'associer à ce qu'on
m'a dit mes collègues parce que quand on
vous voit ici cet après midi c'est
impressionnant et je voudrais remercier
christian et l'ensemble du bureau des
jeunes qui ont réussi un pari qui était
difficile à tenir et qui s'avère un vrai
succès et ça fait vraiment plaisir de
voir notre famille avec une telle
énergie une telle jeunesse réunit cet
après midi donc bravo bravo pour vous
merci aussi à christian pour les montrer
très gentil qui l'a dit tout à l'heure
qui suit sensible juste une petite
différence c'est que effectivement on
n'est pas encore dans le département du
val de marne on est à paris mais ce que
tu m'as dis là christian me donne une
idée peut-être une annexion du bois de
vincennes pendant les dans les semaines
ou les mois qui viennent c'est un peu ça
peut être une bonne idée pour vous dire
moi par rapport à je vais répondre à la
question coralliens à poser mais ce que
je vais vous dire c'est que par
définition si vous êtes à aujourd'hui
comme le disait tout à l'heure mon
collègue c'est que vous êtes convaincus
de la nécessité de s'engager et de
s'engager jeune et je pense que vous
faites le bon choix parce qu'on peut
s'engager en politique à tout moment
mais pour le mieux le faire comme vous
le faite vous comme on l'a fait les uns
et les autres
nous ça fait un peu plus longtemps que
certains autres mais c'est le bon moment
pour le faire pourquoi parce que vous
avez cette énergie cette dynamique des
convictions généralement très forte que
vous voulez porter et donc l'énergie et
le dynamisme que vous avez en vous qui
va vous être utiles pour votre propre
vie personnelle c'est une très bonne
chose dans de mettre ça aussi au service
des autres au service de la france au
service de votre commune au service de
l'intérêt général ça c'est la première
chose qui fait que vous devez vous avez
raison de vous engager maintenant la
seconde chose c'est qu'on dit toujours
que la politique c'est pas un métier
c'est vrai que c'est pas un métier mais
ça doit se faire quand même avec un sens
un sérieux
prophète de façon professionnelle et ça
ça s'apprend la politique ça s'apprend
ça s'apprend en militant sur le terrain
en ce qu on frotte en se confrontant aux
autres au pot aux habitants en essayant
de les écouter aussi est généralement
nos certitudes sont un peu écornée
surtout quand on est jeune on a des
convictions très fortes et bien en
discutant avec les autres on voit aussi
qu'il faut parfois revoir un peu son sa
copie ça répond en partie d'ailleurs à
ce que disait relief ou comment on fait
donc vous avez eu raison de vous engager
maintenant pourquoi faire c'est ça aussi
c'est quel est le sens de l'engagement
le sens de l'engagement c'est pas de
faire je pense que quand on est de
droite c'est cette volonté d'agir ça
nous sépare pas malde de ce que fait la
gauche la gauche généralement il ya
beaucoup de discours beaucoup
d'incantations
beaucoup d'eux souvent de dénonciation
mais quand on regarde concrètement les
choses moi j'ai pris la présidence d'un
département ou sur tous les sujets sur
tous les sujets le département s'est
positionné à prix a fait des schémas a
fait des déclarations des postures des
voeux etc mais quand on regarde
concrètement in fine et les actions qui
sont mises en oeuvre pour les habitants
pour les val de marnais que ce soit sur
la sécurité que ce soit en matière de
transition écologique il n'y a rien la
page est vide et donc le vrai sens de
l'engagement politique le vrai sens pour
quelqu'un de droite c'est de mettre
concrètement en action au service de ses
habitants ses idées et les idées que
nous portons et nos convictions et ce
qui doit faire la différence pour
répondre à ce que disent et aurélien
c'est aussi notre capacité
à tenir nos engagements
on doit annoncer concrètement ce qu'on
veut faire
pourquoi en vaut le faire sincèrement il
ya des gens qui ne sont pas nos
convictions mais s'ils sentent la
sincérité dans l'engagement et qu'il
voit ensuite que cette les engagements
qu'on a pris sont tenus alors la
crédibilité et la et au delà des guides
et compile des convictions politiques et
la troisième chose c'est la méthode est
la méthode je crois que c'est le
rassemblement fédérer les gens c'est
notre rôle la politique ce n'est pas de
diviser c'est pas de cliver c'est
fondamentalement de rassembler et de
fédérer toutes les personnes quelles que
soient leurs origines quelles que soient
leurs convictions de départ est de
mettre cette énergie au service d'un
projet et puis vous savez il n'y a pas
de mystère c'est d'abord les sens de la
politique mais aussi c'est la méthode
pour gagner c'est ce conseil essayez de
faire dans le département du val de
marne on a échoué en 2015 on a tenu
compte de nos échecs parce que ça fait
partie aussi de l'enrichissement
personnel et c'est à partir de ces
échecs à partir de cette capacité de
cette volonté de fédérer au delà de
notre famille politique
évidemment en discutant dialoguant en
veillant à ce que
les
convictions de chacun soient prises en
compte qu'on arrive à rassembler et à
unir je sais que le président du sénat
et particulièrement un exemple en la
matière et c'est comme ça où on a pu
gagner est la dernière chose que je
voulais dire il suffit pas de dire qu'il
faut que les jeunes soient là pour
militer il faut que les jeunes soient là
aussi pour prendre des responsabilités
et c'est le rôle c'est le rôle des gens
qui sont en place comme nous aujourd'hui
de les intégrer au sein de nos
assemblées délibérantes au sein de nos
exécutifs il suffit pas de le dire il
faut aussi là aussi le fer le démontrer
et moi nous on a tenu à le faire les uns
et les autres je sais qu'on est dans nos
collectivités c'est le cas pour tout
vous dire par exemple à la présidence du
département du val de marne maintenant
le premier vp il a moins de 35 ans le
président du groupe il a une trentaine
d'années il ya 3 3bis au vice-président
qui sont ô des moins de 30 ans et c'est
comme ça parce que c'est eux qui nous
apportent leur énergie mais aussi comme
ça qu'ils vont apprendre ensemble on va
pouvoir travailler pour améliorer le
comment dirais-je le quotidien des val
de marnais voilà ce que je vais vous
dire en terminant juste d'un mot parce
que il y a quelqu'un ici
qui est jeune qui a fait la preuve
de son expérience de son talent et qui
va engager dans quelques jours un combat
très dur et j'espère pour lui je lui
souhaite vraiment le plein succès je
veux parler d'hotman othman nasro je lui
souhaite vraiment du conducteur pour lui
mais aussi pour sa commune et pour les
habitants de sa commune une très belle
victoire dans un mois et demi maintenant
[Applaudissements]
merci olivier tes propos laissent une
transition toute trouvée nous avons à
nos côtés hortense chartier et hortense
et une très jeune et lui puisqu'elle a
été élue conseillère municipale à 18 ans
sur une liste qui avait perdu 60 40 dans
une commune de tape plus de vingt mille
habitants elle était cette fois-ci tête
de liste elle a échoué de très peu
apprendre cette commune de bruges en
gironde
la question pourrait poser pourtant
c'est pourquoi tu est reparti au combat
et pourquoi cette fois ci tu es devenu
tête de liste et comment tu vois ton
ancrage territorial pour la suite des
opérations
merci effectivement j'ai été élu à 18
ans sur une liste on m'a fait confiance
et petit à petit les élus de mon groupe
m'ont permis de me laisser des
responsabilités et se sont dit on est
dans une ville très ancré à gauche sur
la métropole pourquoi on enverrait pas
une jeune pour de l'ancrage territorial
pour la laisser monter et ils m'ont
laissé cette possibilité-là de partir en
tant que tête de liste alors
effectivement je rebondis sur le fait
qu'il faut qu'on soit fort mais il faut
qu'on soit accompagnée parce que
heureusement qu'on a un parti derrière
nous qui nous permet
d'apprendre aux jeunes parce qu'être élu
mais ça s'apprend c'est pas non plus
innés et on se retrouve face à des
responsabilités et j'ai souhaité en 2020
mener cette liste à voir des jeunes sur
la liste pour qu'on prépare aussi les
années qui arrivent et effectivement on
a échoué à moins de 500 voix et donc
l'écart s'est réduit donc comme quoi les
gens font aussi confiance à la jeunesse
mais n'hésitez pas à engager vous c'est
vraiment le mot d'aujourd'hui c'est
faites vous confiance allez-y parce
qu'en fait vous êtes l'avenir tout
simplement et on a besoin on recherche
des jeunes sur nos listes vrai que même
pour une candidate jeune j'ai eu du mal
à alors dire mais allez-y pourquoi pas
vous c'est c'est l'élection municipale
c'est une des plus belles élections
puisque on gère le quotidien tout ce qui
nous touche et je pense que
effectivement par l'ancrage local moi je
me suis engagé dans les associations je
me suis engagé pour ma commune et c'est
comme ça que j'ai réussi en 2020 à
pouvoir mener ce combat et je compte
bien y retourner en 2026 pour pour faire
basculer notre commune est sûrement on
espère l'ensemble de la métropole
bordelaise
merci en france
merci pour pour vos témoignages
peut-être une leçon à retenir désormais
c'est que on s'abîme jamais on le disait
à la côte mana l'instant qui va mener
une belle bataille municipale on s'abîme
jamais à prendre des risques en
politique on s'abîme toujours en cours
dans pas de risques et on est
quelques-uns ici avoir échoué avant de
réussir c'est sûrement le sens du combat
politique
les belles batailles sont celles qui
sont difficiles pas celles qui sont
faciles et c'est comme ça qu'on réussit
un jour ou l'autre vous avez maintenant
la parole il ya des micros qui vont
circuler dans la salle deux minutes pour
les questions de minutes pour les
réponses et c'est donc désormais à vous
de poursuivre le débat avec nos
intervenants en général la première
question est toujours la plus compliquée
c'est là aussi vous voyez que nous
n'avons pas préparé de questions parce
que si on les avait préparés vous seriez
déjà manifestés qui veut poser la
première question
levé vous pour pour vous signaler
alors il me semble que là bas
on fait des grands gestes parce que moi
je vois plus avec m donc
moi j'aurai une question pour messieurs
othman nasri
alors où est ce que vous êtes ou est ce
que tu es oui oui je vois dit ben ok
donc j'aurai une question pour monsieur
nasri en temps je sais que vous êtes élu
de trappes je sais qu'il ya une élection
municipale qui approche comment vous
oubliez votre expérience d'élu de
terrain
sachant que c'est une ville on sait où
il y a des difficultés
comment vous pouvez décrire votre
expérience d'élu de terrain dans cette
commune
moi je veux juste vous dire une chose
aurélia l'a dit et pour tous les jeunes
qui sont là de ne pas hésiter à
s'engager parce qu'on se bat pour des
valeurs et dans une ville comme trappe
il ne faut pas croire que les habitants
d'une ville comme trappe ne veulent pas
aussi livre dans la république ça c'est
de ce serait une erreur majeure il ne
faut pas croire que ils ne veulent pas
aussi de la mixité sociale qui ne
veulent pas aussi de la sécurité le
problème c'est que dans les difficultés
que vous mentionnez ils n'en sont pas
les responsables ils en sont les otages
et otage d'un certain nombre d'élus
d'une partie de la gauche et de
l'extrême gauche qui ont fait du
clientélisme leur fonds de commerce qui
ont cru qu en paupérisant leur
population ils allaient se constituer à
vie un électorat captif une boutique
électorale à peu de frais qui et c'est
le cas de la ville de trappes depuis un
an maintenant nous avons un maire dont
l'une des premières décisions a été
d'envoyer des jeunes manifester contre
la police et qui du coup passent leur
temps à jouer les gens les uns contre
les autres les communautés les unes
contre les autres à jouer le clivage à
tout prix avec ce discourt la france ne
vous aime pas non vous m votez pour nous
eh bien ça il faut le combattre partout
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure je le redis
ici à chaque occasion à chaque élection
parce qu'il n'y a pas de territoire ici
qui n'a pas la même dignité il n'y a pas
de citoyens de ce pays qui dans leur
écrasante majorité quel que soit le
territoire n'ont pas envie de république
qui n'ont pas envie de vivre la tête
haute n'ont pas envie qu'on les tire
vers le haut avec de l'emploi plutôt
qu'avec des aides avec 2 les formations
pour les jeunes plutôt que des sorties
des barbecues ont ils ont on a envie
attrape comme ailleurs de vivre dans la
république et on a envie de réussir et
d'excellence ces mots là ne devrait pas
être un mot tabou nulle part dans notre
pays et c'est pour cela que je parte ce
combat là et je vous prie de croire
qu'il ya beaucoup d'habitants de trappes
qui je l'espère vont se reconnaître dans
ce combat aussi et à travers eux c'est
un combat en effet par rapport à ce
qu'on veut faire de notre pays et moi je
le dis c est lui qui joue avec le feu
ils sont peu nombreux on sait de quel
parti de l'échiquier politique ils ont
il faut les combattre pied à pied
[Applaudissements]
vous avez encore la parole c'est à vous
de poursuivre le débat
alors sur ma droite trait sur ma droite
bonjour que pensez vous d'une possible
candidature d'eric zemmour à la
présidentielle
on va prendre une deuxième question pour
pouvoir répondre à deux questions en
même temps parce que celle ci n'est pas
suffisamment passionnant pour qui mérite
une réponse non on va on va y répondre
évidemment
mais peut-être une deuxième une deuxième
question et on va faire par séries de
deux questions et on vous répondra
évidemment
seconde question
bonjour merci beaucoup pour vos
interventions alors moi j'habite au
xxème arrondissement de paris c'est un
arrondissement un bastion historique de
la gauche donc j'ai deux questions
nous avons des difficultés à affronter à
la gauche dans cet arrondissement mais
nous avons une grosse difficulté avec
l'absentéisme que je qualifie du premier
parti politique de france sincèrement
alors comment dire aux gens comment leur
convaincre que les institutions de
l'état sont censés le représenter
comment réconcilier
nos voisins les habitants de notre
arrondissement avec la politique et
comment leur dire pour ne pour ne plus
croire que la droite que les
républicains n'est pas le parti d'une
certaine bourgeoisie d'une certaine
élite qui
voilà qui ne veut pas faire entendre la
voix du peuple merci à vous merci pour
pour ta question je pense qu'on en
prenne une troisième
pour pouvoir ensuite se répartir les
réponses est ce qu'il ya une troisième
question
bon commençons à répondre à ces deux
questions je vais laisser qui le
souhaitent apporter des réponses
peut-être sur la première question que
vous vous posiez chacun est libre de
penser évidemment ici ce qu'il veut mais
il ya une différence fondamentale entre
ceux qui commentent et ce qu'ils font
vous avez ici des femmes et des hommes
comme au premier rang d'ailleurs qui
tous les jours on les mains dans le
cambouis qui sont pas tous les jours
seulement sur des plateaux de télévision
confortablement maquillée avec des
cravates satiné mais qui toutes les
semaines vont sur le terrain souvent se
faire engueuler souvent se faire remuer
et avoir en face d'eux une vraie réalité
je pense qu'il faut juste comprendre qu
en politique ce que j n'engage que moi
qu'en politique il ya deux types de
personnalité il ya les spectateurs et
commentateurs il ya les acteurs c'est
toujours beaucoup plus difficile d'être
un acteur que d'être un spectateur est
le vrai courage politique c'est pas
celui de commenter le vrai courage
politique c'est celui d'être un jour
candidat à une élection est d'être un
jour élu à une élection c'est sûrement
ce qui fait la différence entre
quelques-uns d'entre nous collectivement
et quelques autres qui voient la
politique de très très loin peut-être
sur ce sujet est-ce que celles et ceux
qui qui préside des exécutifs pouvez
nous dire à quel point au quotidien vous
arrivez à faire que vos valeurs vos
convictions celle de la droite
républicaine sur la gestion de vos
finances sur les questions de solidarité
aussi parce que la droite républicaine
c'est aussi la main tendue à ceux qui en
ont besoin comment on installe le mérite
dans des politiques publiques du
quotidien comprendre que lorsqu'on est
maire lorsqu'on est président de
département il ya des politiques de
droite et les politiques de gauche
comment est ce qu'on fait cela comment
est-ce qu'on traduit ses convictions
dans l'action concrète se présente
département peut-être par rapport à la
question que posait concernant le fait
que la droite ne doit pas apparaître
comme la représentante de la bourgeoisie
on va dire c'était ça le sens de ta
question moi ce qui m'a frappé aux
élections municipales toi dans ma
commune c'est que le meilleur bureau le
meilleur score j'ai fait c'est un bureau
qui est exclusivement composée d'un
quartier de logement social
exclusivement les gars type où on va
dire entre guillemets plus bourgeois
c'est dans ce quartier populaire que
j'ai fait le meilleur score et pourquoi
je pense et ce n'est pas propre c'est
pas propre à mon cas c'est le cas dans
de nombreux
maires de droite en ile de france pour
quoi et ça rejoint ce que disait othman
tout à l'heure parce que tout simplement
les gens dans ces quartiers veulent quoi
ils veulent comme tout le monde
que leurs enfants réussissent
qu'on les tire vers le haut
qu'aux cubes de qu'on leur offre un
cadre de vie agréable comme tout un
chacun a droit quelle que soit sa
catégorie de professionnels sociale etc
c'est ça que demandent les gens et si
les gens voient que on s'occupe d'eux
que ce que l'on dit que ce qu'on leur a
dit qu'on allait faire on le réalise et
bien ce il n'y a plus cette barrière qui
pourrait être celle que tu évoquais de
la droite représentants de la
bourgeoisie la droite elle est populaire
tout simplement quant à celle qu'occupe
des gens tout simplement sans discours
nécessairement à aider grande conviction
et ceram et concrète car à droite
concrètes est ce que disait exactement
othman c'est que les gens dans les
quartiers qui sonné plus défavorisés
appel qu'à une chose c'est vivre comme
les autres avoir les mêmes droits avoir
le même avenir pour leurs enfants c'est
ça qu'ils demandent et c'est ça qui fait
le pacte républicain à mon sens
oui donc pour pour rebondir sur ce que
dit olivier je souscris totalement quand
vous êtes aux responsabilités dans une
collectivité territoriale et que vous
voulez gagner l'élection il faut aller
au delà de votre socle pour aller au
delà de votre stock parfois il faut
bénéficier de concours circonstances
mais une fois que vous y êtes et que
vous voulez être réélu il faut réaliser
il faut être dans l'opérationnel est
dans le concret et c'est en ça que
le mandat d'élu local et de mer en
particulier prend tout son sens comme
celui de président de département
puisque vous êtes dans l'opérationnalité
vous êtes dans la la réalisation est
très souvent vous savez il y à des
images d'epinal qui consiste à dire que
la gauche s'occuperait les avantages de
social que la droite et que la droite
s'occuperait davantage de régalien que
la gauche bien sûr qu'il ya des grands
marqueurs entre nous et nos opposants du
parti socialiste mais la réalité
concrète sur le terrain moi je le prends
dans ma ville vous savez on a neuf
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville et à 50 de nationalité à
limeuil ça peut paraître surprenant mais
c'est une réalité en terme de logement
social en termes de politique de la
ville en terme d'aménagement des
quartiers prioritaires nous avons fait
beaucoup plus que nos prédécesseurs sur
six ans que eux en 25 ans et ça vous
savez la population elle nous attend au
tournant là dessus et aurélien le disais
tout à l'heure la grosse force que nous
avons nous élus locaux c'est que nous
sommes à portée de baffe de l'électeur
bien que quand vous allez sur un marché
vous croiser des gens des vrais gens qui
vous disent monsieur le maire là mes
poubelles n'ont pas été ramassées là ma
fille s'est fait chahuter à l'entrée de
la cage d'escalier là il y à des trafics
de stupéfiants et donc pour assembler le
mieux c'est d'abord d'arriver aux
manettes c'est un peu la difficulté
c'est très souvent quand vous combattez
pour répondre à votre question des
opposants politiques qui sont parfois là
depuis des décennies c'est pas toujours
facile de les renverser mais vous aurez
toujours parce que vous êtes jeune une
fenêtre de tir parce que le maire
d'arrondissement où le maire de la ville
va un moment donné être usé par le
pouvoir très souvent quand un camp est
aux manettes sur une collectivité depuis
longtemps secret des jeux de tensions à
l'intérieur même de ceux qui dirigent la
collectivité depuis longtemps et là vous
avez une fenêtre de tir le jour vous
avez la capacité de rentrer dans cette
fenêtre de tir il faut être meilleur que
rapidement et c'est souvent assez facile
puisque quand vous êtes aux manettes sur
10 ans 15 ans 20 ans 30 ans a fortiori
un siècle comme c'était le cas chez moi
vous avez des habitudes qui secrets qui
sont des mauvaises habitudes et là vous
pouvez prouver par l'opérationnalité de
vos engagements et de politique de vos
politiques publiques pardon que vous
êtes meilleur que ce que vous avez battu
donc n'hésitez pas à vous engager et et
un dernier message à la jeunesse vous
savez si vous êtes là
on est à la veille de la rentrée pour
certains pour d'autres vous êtes déjà
rentrés vous êtes tous des têtes bien
faites vous êtes tous des têtes bien
pleines et comme tous les gens
intelligents très souvent c'est
l'apanage des gens intelligents ils ont
tendance à se sous-estimer
et vous savez moi même quand j'ai
commencé à faire de la politique j'avais
très peur de mes adversaires je me suis
dit s'ils sont là depuis tant d'années
c'est qu'ils doivent être quand même
très fort très organisé et puis au bout
de dix ans vous vous l'êtes surtout
rendu compte que vous avez sur estimer
les autres et que vous êtes souvent
sous-estimée
[Applaudissements]
oui peut-être juste sur sur l'abstention
je suis demandé comment comment faire et
comment allait nous entre les deux tours
malgré le covin on a quand même doubler
le nombre de votants et je pense qu a
pas de secret simplement mettre ses
baskets et revenir aux bonnes vieilles
méthodes on a fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de porte à porte et c'est ce
qui nous permet au second tour de faire
entrer aussi un maximum d'élus sur le
conseil municipal
je vous propose qu'on prenne une
dernière série de questions avant de
passer aux ateliers qui vont vous
occuper tout l'après midi
est ce que quelqu'un a une autre
question à poser à nos intervenants
pardon oui attend on va t'amener un
micro je suis à ma gauche cette fois ci
alors une question sur ma gauche une
question sur mon centre puits forés une
question sur ma droite aussi ça
équilibrerait
alors autant les micros
ok bon bah on commence en face de moi
alors bonjour je me présente en jeu
bruno je suis étudiant en master rse et
nous sommes chez les jeunes républicains
ce membre des jeunes républicains de la
sat
le grand problème chez les jeunes
actuellement c'est l'emploi et
je voudrais bien savoir quelle est la
stratégie innovante que nous devons
faire pour octroi pour employer plus de
chances aux jeunes
qui on va prendre une seconde question
comme on a la chance d'avoir des élus
terrain qu'ils sont
très jeune dino d'où tu viens moi je
viens de picardie je m'appelle cédric
saint sulpice et je voulais rebondir
effectivement oui la france n'est pas
raciste et je voulais savoir comme vous
êtes des îles terrain et comme ici il ya
beaucoup de jeunes c'est un concrets
liés à la jeunesse républicaine
est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes frappé
par l'augmentation de la délinquance qui
touchent les plus jeunes je voulais
c'était juste ma question
merci beaucoup pour pour ta question et
dernière question
ici sur ma gauche
bonjour
bonjour à vous et merci de m'écouter
aujourd'hui j'aurais souhaité vous poser
une question quels conseils
pourriez-vous nous apporter lorsque nous
souhaitons dialoguer et apporter un réel
débat d'idées avec certains de nos
adversaires politiques qui très souvent
refusent toute contradiction merci à
vous
merci beaucoup je compose de d'apporter
quelques éléments de réponse sur sur la
question de l'emploi othman nous en dire
un mot également
sur la question de l'emploi je pense
juste l'exemple de 2,2 de ma commune
erstein est une ville qui a un taux un
taux de chômage entre 9 et 11% à peu
près mais chez nous le problème il est
il répond quand même en partie à la
question il n'est pas forcément celui de
l'emploi j'ai des entreprises qui
viennent souvent me voir on a des sièges
nationaux avec des entreprises qui font
130 millions de chiffres d'affaires des
entreprises de btp des entreprises de
joaillerie des pelles entreprises et
bien ce qu'on ne trouve pas aujourd'hui
c'est pas forcément ce problème là de
d'avoir des personnes qui ne trouvent
pas d'emploi c'est de trouver justement
dans ces entreprises dans ces
entreprises il ya des savoir-faire de
trouver du monde qui peut répondre à une
demande de des patrons est aujourd'hui
le vrai sujet sur l'emploi je pense
surtout c'est un sujet que la droite a
toujours récupérer parce que la droite
c'est avant tout la méritocratie c'est
vraiment le sujet de l'apprentissage on
est dans une conjoncture aujourd'hui ou
moi j'ai des entreprises qui ne trouvent
pas d'emploi
c'est un vrai sujet ça donc aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour
éventuellement réduire le taux de
chômage je pense que c'est déjà en
premier à l'école et à l'école la
réforme de l'apprentissage elle me
semble essentiel parce que on a incarné
depuis trop longtemps dans deux
gouvernements qu'ils n'étaient pas les
nôtres là comment dire le fait qu'il
fallait faire les études les plus
longues pour être nécessairement dans un
schéma personnel un schéma profit net
était le plus abouti mais aujourd'hui
moi dans mon terrain on a des personnes
qui ont des vrais métiers des métiers
d'excellence je vois une entreprise en
particulier de joaillerie à qui il
manque 40 personnes 40 personnes pour un
travail qui qui tombent tous les jours
ils font les joailleries les plus
importantes du luxe en matière vigny
dans de gamme d'accès à tout le monde et
bien aujourd'hui il ne trouve pas donc
le sujet aussi de l'emploi chez nous
déjà c'est d'essayer de faire cette
rencontre entre les patrons et les
demandeurs d'emploi mais avant tout sur
une question plus longue il passe
vraiment sur une réforme de
l'apprentissage ou même une réforme tout
simplement aussi des études supérieures
othman oui ça rejoint la question de
savoir comment on décline nos valeurs en
dispositif concret et sur l'emploi des
jeunes ou sur la valeur travail
d'ailleurs et là dessus un exemple très
simple qu'on a fait en ile-de-france
avec valérie pécresse s'est tout
simplement de voir les emplois qu'ils
n'étaient pas pourvues et de créer des
formations courtes et qualifiantes sur
les emplois et des formations rémunérées
je veux le dire parce que autant je me
pose très clairement je crois qu'on les
nombreux ici au rsa jeunes est une forme
de condescendance il n'est pas question
de donner l'argent à des jeunes pour
qu'ils restent chez eux à ne rien faire
ça veut dire qu'on considère qu'ils ne
peuvent rien faire de mieux que d'être
dans l'oise yves t ça ne peut pas être
un modèle de société acceptable par
contre effectivement qu'on flèche les
aux jeunes vers les métiers qui
recrutent ça paraît d'une logique
absolue est effectivement plus ça répond
aux besoins des employeurs avant la
crise nous avions l'île de france sept
cent mille demandeurs d'emploi mais en
même temps cent mille emplois non
pourvus dans des secteurs comme le btp
la sécurité privée l'environnement le
médico-social et j'en passe et d'autre
eh bien nous avons identifié 45000
places de formation dans ces métiers là
rémunéré 670 euros par mois à condition
de suivre la formation jusqu'au bout et
au bout il ya 70% de chances de trouver
un emploi simplement il faut le faire
savoir et c'est vrai que nos pouvoirs
publics doivent comprendre qu'il faut
qu'on réinvente de nouveaux dispositifs
qu'on réforme l'information
professionnelle comme modernise
probablement tout cela pour toucher un
public qui à qui on ne sait plus parler
aujourd'hui c'est vrai parfois dans le
monde politique c'est aussi vrai dans
les dispositifs concrets qui existent
aujourd'hui pour permettre aux jeunes
d'aller vers l'emploi encore faut-il et
bien qu'on aille aussi les chercher leur
donner envie par un discours clair qu'il
soit pas un discours de victimisation
il avait rose
sur le sur le sujet de la violence alors
moi je suis maire d'une commune de 43
mille habitants dans un département
rural le département de l'indre et là
aussi j'allais dire là aussi en
comparaison avec les grandes cités
urbaines on connaît une augmentation
réelle de la violence chez les jeunes il
ya une semaine jour pour jour samedi
dernier à la même heure devant la mairie
j'avais mille personnes qui terminait
une marche blanche suite à une rixe
intervenu quelques semaines avant sur la
même place de la mairie une nuit à 2
heures du matin entre un jeune qui
sortait d'une soirée avec des amis qui
traversait la place qui a eu une
altercation gratuite avec un groupe
oisif qui est elle a un groupe qui est
connu pour faire partie d'une bande de
dealers
l'altercation est l'appât et ailier du
tout à une transaction de stupéfiants
quoi que ce soit mais il ya eu des
échanges de coups
qui ont été rapides un jeune de 26 ans
est tombé tombé dans le coma décédé
quelques jours après
l'agresseur il a 17 ans et il a été
identifié on est une ville très
vidéoprotégé
incarcéré dès le lendemain mais ces deux
drames en fait un drame pour évidemment
la victime de 26 ans et sa famille mais
un drame pour l'auteur de 17 ans et sa
famille également alors quand on a dit
ça quelle est la solution cette
augmentation de la violence on la
connaît lié au phénomène de trafic de
stupéfiants mais également liés à
l'accès facile à la pornographie au fait
qu' on perd un peu les valeurs on sait
plus qui est bien ce qui est pas bien on
perd la notion de la vie une vie ça peut
se perdre rapidement ça peut gâcher les
parcours professionnels des parcours
personnel comment résoudre ce problème
c'est vraiment un défi pour notre
société parce que c'est une espèce de
gangrène généralisée qui fait qu' il n'y
a pas une solution au problème c'est une
multitude d'actions à mener on parlait
tout à l'heure d'apprentissage
d'éducation moi je crois beaucoup
dispositif de réussite éducative qui
fasse que aux côtés de l'éducation
nationale on puisse accompagner les
enfants qui dans leur contexte familial
dans leur contexte de quartier ont pas
les facultés de d'avoir une éducation
j'ai à dire normal j'allais dire comme
on l'a les uns les autres comme une
bonne partie peut-être des gens dans
cette salle l'ont peut-être pas comme on
l'a tous eu moi je suis d'une famille
très modeste on n'allait pas au cinéma
n'allait pas dans les musées on avait on
a je suis allé à l'école municipale
public j'ai pas eue j'ai pas fait de
grandes écoles et tout ça est malgré
tout mes parents m'ont appris la valeur
du travail du respect et l importance de
la vie quoi voilà de la notion humaine
et du fait que même les querelles les
plus fortes justifiait pas une agression
et et donc on a beaucoup à faire les
élus l'a tué c'est vraiment un anneau
grand challenge sur lequel il faut qu'on
passe du temps et qu'on mette des moyens
s'est pas uniquement d'ailleurs des
moyens financiers c'est d'essayer de de
reprendre en main un peu la population
pas que les jeunes parce que le problème
il n'y a pas que les jeunes c'est vrai
que cette violence allait fortement
constater aujourd'hui chez les jeunes
mais c'est vraiment un ensemble de
responsabilités je vois gilles platret
quai en face moi
chalon sur saône aussi il connaît ces
situations là il est très attaché à
faire de la proximité tout à l'heure on
parlait des élections moi les meilleurs
scores je les fais dans les quartiers
populaires aussi gillot si aujourd'hui
on n'est plus élu majoritairement dans
les quartiers de centre ville mais parce
que on a pris conscience nous
qu' il fallait qu'on travaille dans ces
quartiers là et qu'il fallait qu'on
s'occupe de cette jeunesse qui a qui
peut être facilement des oeuvres est
quoi mais qui est pas uniquement
maintenant dans les quartiers qui est
aussi les plans de rénovation urbaine
vous savez on démolit les ensembles et
on essaye de répartir à juste titre la
population mais ce qui fait du coup dans
tous les quartiers maintenant on a aussi
des poches de de pauvreté et il faut
faire attention aux politiques qui
viserait qui a eu mettre les moyens que
dans les quartiers populaires parce
qu'aujourd'hui les enfants nécessiteux
les familles nécessiteuses elles sont
réparties partout sur le territoire
alexandra merci gilles
juste rapidement pour rebondir sur les
deux sujets convient d'évoquer d'abord
celui de la justice et de la délinquance
juvénile que tu évoqué à l'instant qui
n'est pas finalement récente mais qui
c'est vrai s'accentue aujourd'hui les
guetteurs ont 11 ans et au sein du sénat
soit la majorité notre président bruno
retailleau ici présent que je salue nous
nous efforçons en tout cas à nous battre
pour justement accentuer cette réponse
pénale et on a besoin aussi sur le
terrain que ce soit en tant que
parlementaire mais surtout pour les les
pour ceux qui tiennent les collectivités
de moyens de moyens sur le terrain à
travers et la police de moyens aussi
davantage de magistrats pour avoir une
réponse pénale ferme c'est pas le tout
de pouvoir constater il faut qu'on
puisse avoir les moyens derrière de
pouvoir sanctionner sur le deuxième
sujet que celui de l'emploi et des
étudiants c'est vrai que les étudiants
ont tendance à tous se fourvoyer partir
faire un master 5 ans d'études à
l'université parce que c'est la facilité
parce que l'université aujourd'hui offre
énormément de possibilités
le problème il faut le prendre à la
source si on a travaillé dessus sur
aurélien sur l'emploi l'orientation elle
se fait dès le collège pourquoi
l'alternance pourquoi l'apprentissage
sont aujourd'hui des voies de garage en
allemagne
on sait on sait que cette thématique là
est complètement différente et que ça
permet justement de trouver de l'emploi
donc il faut redorer réforme et
valoriser l'apprentissage qui est loin
d'être une voie de garage bien au
contraire qui est une voie d'excellence
et par cela on arrivera à trouver des
métiers qui correspond à la demande et
au marché de l'emploi dans les
alpes-maritimes on a une forte industrie
du tourisme on incite et ont créé à
l'université ou dans des écoles des
formations diplômantes sur le tourisme à
bac + 2 qui permettent d'obtenir alors
un emploi et surtout de répondre à cette
demande de main d'oeuvre parce que on
l'a constaté pendant cette saison
estivale avec en plus la problématique
du pass sanitaires il ya un véritable
manque de personnel 20% de postes à
pourvoir dans l'industrie touristique
cet été il ya un vrai problème il faut
trouver le problème et le soigner à la
source
merci beaucoup alexandra pensée pour ces
veaux qui seront les mots de conclusion
avant que nous puissions passer à la
suite du programme merci guillaume
d'avoir animé cette table ronde merci à
chacune et chacun des intervenants vous
le voyez ici vous avez des praticiens de
la politique pas des théoriciens de la
politique et je pense qu'on peut tous se
mettre d'accord sur un beau message qui
suit la promesse républicaine ce qui
nous a permis un jour d'être élu c'est
la promesse républicaine et ce qui est
une solution pour notre pays c'est la
promesse républicaine ce n'est pas un
problème c'est une solution la promesse
républicaine merci à chacune et chacun
de la faire vivre au quotidien de faire
vivre nos valeurs et les valeurs de
notre république et de notre beau pays
désormais nous passons à la suite du
programme avec la présentation du projet
par deux nos collègues parlementaires
dans quelques minutes merci de votre
attention et votre participation
[Applaudissements]